mr. president we just learned that Nancy
Pelosi isn't out she's sending articles
of impeachment next week to the Senate
what's your well I think it's ridiculous
she should have sent him a long time ago
it just it belittles the process what
they've done to impeachment it's like I
was interviewed by a very very good
writer
reporter somebody that you know very
well I could say Bob Woodward he said
he's doing something and this time I
said maybe I'll sit down because
nobody's done more than me I mean nobody
if you look at three years with the
economy with regulations with the tax
cuts with everything well the things
we've rebuilt our military our military
was totally depleted our military was
old and depleted and he said you know
you don't look like somebody who's under
impeachment as you know he slightly
covered Nixon and he covered Clinton but
Bob Woodward he said you actually looked
like you've won everything you look
happy
I said I am happy so maybe I'm wired a
little bit different managers anyone
that you would prefer to see she have a
team no we have a team but her
impeachment managers I would love to ask
a couple of their people some questions
like Schiff why did he lie why did he
make up my statement totally made it up
but again the whole thing unraveled when
I put in the transcript because it's all
about the transcript and it's all about
the president of Ukraine saying he did
nothing how long do you think this will
last well it depends if they have a
trial probably takes a few days or a
week and unless we want to have a bigger
trial will we bring in the whistleblower
which I'd love to do and I'd love to
bring in the the informer who
disappeared I'd love to bring into
second whistleblower who disappeared I'd
love to bring in the Inspector General
why did he bring it up there he should
have never done it he didn't want to see
the call he didn't want to see the call
he took this whistleblower who's a fraud
he took the whistleblowers report and he
put it in they said to him no no if it's
if that's the case if you have to do
that what we'll do is we'll show you the
actual call no no no I don't want to say
it what's that all about why did he do
that inspector general so I'd like to
interview the inspector general why did
he do that
and put everybody through about future
presidents what this is gonna do to the
president say in the future I think it
cheapened the word impeachment I think
impeachment is a very ugly word but I
think this cheapened the word
impeachment I think Nancy Pelosi and she
you know because he's corrupt I mean
here's a guy stands up at the United
States Congress and repeats a
conversation except it was a fraud he
made up a conversation he was saying my
conversation and it was totally wrong
and he knew it he said don't call me
I'll call you that's from the Godfather
that's from that's a mafia statement I
never said that
he said eight times quid pro quo it was
no times he made up a conversation and
repeated it in front of Congress and
because he has immunity we can't do
anything about it I'd like to say why
did you do that now these people are
frauds and it's very bad know they've
cheapened the word impeachment it's a
bad word to start off with I really said
it's an ugly word to me it's a very ugly
word but maybe it played to our benefit
when we talk about impeachment now it
looks like McConnell is agreeing with
Josh Hawley's proposition to dismiss
these articles of impeachment if Pelosi
doesn't send them over my question new
is why not have them dismissed today
why wouldn't McConnell just say we're
done with these games or do you want to
try all in many ways why like a trial
and I'd love to have sleepy Joe Biden
I'd love to have his son I call him
where's hunter I've changed his first
name to where where's hunter I'd love to
have the whistleblower who wrote a fake
report the whistleblower is a person
that is you know you know who the
whistleblower is by the way everybody
knows who the whistleblowers but now
we're still working in the White House
everybody I don't want to say but
everybody knows about the whistleblower
and they know about the whistleblowers
lawyer but then do you remember there
was a second whistleblower I want to
know what happened to the second
whistleblower what happened to the
informer remember that an informer they
all disappeared when I gave the
transcript because I gave a transcript
and that blew everything apart because
we have inaccurate and if the only thing
covered by the hearings was that now
people agree everybody even our
great lieutenant colonel please call him
Lieutenant Colonel our great lieutenant
colonel agrees that the transcript was
accurate I think he had one word
difference we'll change the one word it
meant absolutely nothing the transcript
was professionally done by the best
people there are just one second so we
have a transcript they never thought I'd
release it they probably never thought I
have it I can only say thank goodness
they have it because I would have been
falsely accused and it would have been
sadly my word against them but we had
other people on that call think of this
I was gonna do something wrong on a call
where I know there are many people
listening always the president of
Ukraine said I did absolutely nothing
wrong he said I had no pressure
whatsoever he didn't even know what we
were talking about and we called them
before I released the transcript because
it's a terrible thing to have to release
a conversation with a leader from
another country it's a terrible thing I
mean what are other countries other than
Ukraine what are they saying so anyway
they have no case why not call Bolton
why not allow him to testify this thing
it's bogus I would have no problem other
than one thing you can't be in the White
House as president future I'm talking
about future many future presidents and
have a security adviser anybody having
to do with security and legal and other
things well I think you have to for the
sake of the office I would love
everybody to testify I like Mick to
testify I like Mike Pompeo to testify I
like Rick Perry to testify
I want everybody but there are things
that you can't do from the standpoint of
executive privilege you have to maintain
that so we'll see where it all goes but
especially a national security adviser
you can't have him explaining all of
your statements about national security
concerning Russia China and North Korea
everything you just can't do this Paul I
think for the good of the office look
Nancy Pelosi will go down as probably
the least successful Speaker of the
House in the history of our nation she
has done nothing the only thing she's
done is she finally got done one of the
best trade deals our country has ever
the USMC a that's with Mexico and Canada
but I did that she doesn't even know
what it says she has no idea what it
says she was forced to do that you know
why she wouldn't have done it but she
did nothing so now she can say I signed
something she is obsessed with
impeachment she has done nothing she's
gonna go down as one of the worst
speakers in the history of our country
now
in all fairness she's hurting our
country
she's very bad for our country and she's
become a crazed lunatic but she will go
down as I think maybe the worst speaker
in the history of our country
she'll be overthrown pretty soon because
she's doing very little and the people
are tired of it and she's controlled by
the radical left she's controlled by aoc
she's controlled by this Talib it's
another great one
and she's controlled by Omar we just
heard that they are thinking about
adding another article of impeachment
they're floating this to include the
events of the last few weeks here's what
Chuck Schumer just said over the past
few weeks there have been several clue
crucial disclosures of evidence that
appear to further incriminate the
president each disclosure bolstering the
argument we Democrats have made for a
trial that features the relevant
witnesses and documents your reaction to
their potentially adding two articles of
impeachment they still haven't delivered
through the Senate floor so they can't
win an election that's going to take
place in ten months they know that and
the only thing they can do it's like
with their congressman green when he
said we can't beat him we have to
impeach him and they all know that
they're making things up this is the
craziest thing anyone's ever seen and
the two articles that they put in as you
know they're not crimes they're not
they're not even allowed to be put in
it's a disgrace the weakness of their
case but they're still trying to rebrand
this is something I think it's never
seen anything like that I think it's
incredible I think it's really hurting
them look my numbers are the highest ed
my poll numbers you have this this guy
that goes on television all the time it
gives phony numbers my poll no as you
know my poll numbers right now today
the highest they've ever been and by the
way people love that we took out this
horrible terrorist they love its Alemany
they love that we took him out they
think it's so fantastic he should have
been taken out over the list 20 years by
somebody he should have been taken out a
long time ago but my numbers are the
highest they've ever been and a lot of
it's because of the impeachment coax
it's a hoax how would you like to be to
two and a half years I'm under
investigation
federal investigation before I even ran
in my opinion before I came down the
escalator but from the time I came down
the escalator I'd been under
investigation they found nothing they
found nothing
who else do you think in Washington now
while fear could have withstood it no
think of it not only would stood it
mentally and I think you know somebody
it actually energizes you yeah because
it makes me angry but think who else
could have wished that you take some of
these Democrat senators they couldn't
withstand it you know what would happen
number one that fold up like an umbrella
and number two they'd be guilty of a lot
of stuff